so if I'm being honestly myself
when I imagine the universe so first
thing I imagine uh about our world is
that we humans and me certainly is one
particular human
uh no very
my first assumption is I know almost
nothing about how anything works so
first of all that actually applies for
for things that humans do know like uh
their quantum mechanics and all the
things that there's different expertises
that I just have not dedicated to so
even even that starting point but if we
take all of knowledge as human
civilization we know almost nothing
that's kind of an assumption I have
because it seems like we keep
discovering Mysteries and it seems like
history human history is defined by
moments when we said okay we pretty much
figured it all out and then you realize
a century later you've when you said
that you didn't figure out anything okay
so that's like a starting point the
second thing I have is
I feel like the entirety of the universe
is just filled with alien civilizations
statistically
there's
the important thing that enables that
belief for me is that they don't have to
be human-like they can be anything and
it's just the fact that life exists and
just seeing the way life is on Earth
that it just finds a way it finds a way
in so many different complicated
environments it finds a way whatever
that force is that same Force has to
find a way elsewhere also
but but then if I'm also being honest
and I I don't know how many hours in a
day I spend
seriously considering the possibility
that we're alone
I don't know what I'm when I when my
heart is in mind or filled with wander I
think about all the different life
that's out there
but to really imagine that we're alone
like really imagine all the vastness
that's out there were alone that not
even bacteria
I would say you don't have to believe
that we are alone
um but you have to admit it's a
possibility of our ignorance of the
universe so far
um
you can have a belief about something
and absence of evidence
and Carl Sagan famously described as the
definition of faith if you believe
something when there's no evidence you
have faith that there's life in the
universe but you can't
you can't demonstrate you can't prove it
mathematically you can't show me
evidence of that
um but is there some some mathematically
math is a funny thing is there I mean
the way physicists think like intuition
so it's a basic reasoning
is there some value to that well I'd say
there's certainly you can certainly make
a very good argument I think you've kind
of already made one just the vastness of
the universe is is the is the default
argument people often turn to that
surely there should be others out as
hard to imagine
um there are order of 10 to the 22 stars
in our observable universe and so really
the question comes down to what's the
probability of one of those 10 to 22
planets let's say earth like planets if
they all have earth like planets
um going on to form life
spontaneously that's the process of
abiogenesis the spontaneous emergence of
life
also the word spontaneous is the
funniest okay maybe when you spontaneous
but um
not not beings they say uh seeded by say
some sure some other civilization or
something like this it naturally emerges
because even the words spontaneous makes
it seem less likely yeah like there's
there's just this chemistry and
extremely random process it could be a
very gradual process over millions of
years have growing complexity in
chemical networks maybe there's a force
in the universe that pushes it towards
interesting complexity pockets of
complexity that ultimately creates
something like life which we can't
possibly Define yet and sometimes it
manifests itself into something that
looks like humans but it could be a
totally different kind of computational
information processing system that we're
too dumb to even visualize yeah I mean
certainly I mean it's kind of weird that
complexity develops a door right because
um it seems like the opposite to our
physical intuition if you're training in
physics of entropy that things should
you know complexity is hard to
spontaneously emote I shouldn't say
spontaneously but hard to emerge in
general
um and so that that's an interesting
problem I think there's been certainly
from an evolutionary perspective you do
see growing complexity and there's a
nice argument I think it's by gold who
who shows that if you have a certain
amount of complexity
um it can either become less complex or
more complex through random mutation and
the less complex things are stripping
away something something that was
necessary potentially to their survival
and so in general that's that's going to
be not particularly useful in its
survival and so it's going to be
detrimental to strip away a significant
amount of its useful traits whereas if
you add something the most uh typical
thing that you add is probably not
useful at all it's probably just uh it
doesn't really affect its survival
negatively but it neither does it
provide any significant benefit but
sometimes on rare occasions of course it
will be of benefit and so if you're I
have a certain level of complexity it's
hard to go back in complexity but it's
fairly easy to go forward with enough
bites at the charity you will eventually
build up in complexity in that so it
tends to be why obviously complexity
growing in in certainly in an
evolutionary sense but also perhaps it's
operating in chemical Network that led
to the emergence of life I guess the
real uh problem I have with with the
numbers game just come back to that is
that we are talking about a certain
probability of that occurring it may be
to go from the primordial soup however
you want to call it the ingredients that
the earth started with the organic
molecules the probability of going from
that initial condition to something that
was capable of darwinian natural
selection that maybe we could Define as
life the probability of that is maybe
one percent one percent of the time that
happens in which case you're right the
universe will be absolutely teeming with
life but it could also be 10 to the
power minus 10 in which case it's one
per Galaxy or 10 to the power of minus
100 in which case the vast majority of
universes even do not have life within
it or 90 or 90 said one percent you said
one percent but it could be 90 if the
conditions the chemical conditions of a
planet are correct or a moon are correct
I admit that it could be any of those
numbers and the challenges we just have
no
rigorous reason to expect why 90 is any
because we're talking about a
probability of a probability
what is is 90 more a priori likely than
10 to the power minus 20. well the thing
is we do have an observation n of one of
birth
and uh it's difficult to know what to do
with that what kind of intuition you
build build on top of that because on
Earth it seems like life finds a way
okay in all kinds of conditions in all
kinds of crazy conditions good and it's
able to like build up from the basic
chemistry you could say okay
uh maybe it takes a little bit of time
to develop some complicated technology
like mitochondria I don't know like
photosynthesis
fine but it seems to figure it out
figure it out and like do it extremely
well yeah but I would say you're
describing a different process I mean
um maybe I'm I'm at fault for separating
these two processes but to me you're
describing basically natural selection
Evolution at that point
um whereas I'm really describing
abiogenesis which is to me a separate
distinct process do you limit it to
human scientists yes but why would it be
a separate process why why is the birth
of Life a separate process from the
process of Life
Why is the
I mean we're uncomfortable with the fir
we are comfortable the Big Bang we're
uncomfortable with the first thing I
think like where did this come from
right so I think I would say I just
twist that question around and say what
you're saying why is it a different
process
um why and I would say why shouldn't it
be a different process which isn't
really a good defense except to say that
we we have
we have knowledge of how naturally
Evolution natural selection Evolution
works we think we understand that
process we have almost no information
about the earlier stages of how life
immersed on our planet it may be that
you're right and it is a part of a
Continuum it may be that it is also a
distinct
improbable set of circumstances that led
to the emergence of Life as a scientist
I'm just trying to be open-minded to
both possibilities if I assert that life
must be everywhere
to me you run the risk of experimenters
bias
um if you think you know what the answer
is if you look at an Earth-like planet
and you're a new a preconditioned to
think there's a 90 chance of Life on
this planet it's going to at some level
affect your interpretation of that data
whereas if I however critical you might
be of the agnosticism that I impose upon
myself
remain open to both possibilities then I
trust in myself to make a fairer
assessment as to the reality of that
evidence for life
yeah but I I wonder sort of
scientifically and and that's really
beautiful to hear and inspiring to hear
uh I I wonder scientifically how many
firsts
we truly know of
like and then we don't eventually
explain as as actually
a a step number one million in a long
process so I think that's a really
interesting thing if there's truly first
in this universe like you know for us
the whatever happened at the Big Bang is
is a kind of first the origin of stuff
but it's just again
um
it seems like history shows that we'll
figure out that it's actually a
continuation of something but then
physicists say that time is emergent and
then our causality and time is is a very
human kind of construct that's very
possible that all of this so there could
be really firsts of a thing to which we
attach a name
so whatever we call life
maybe there is an origin of it yeah and
I would also say I'm open to the idea of
it being part of a continuation but the
continuation maybe is more broader and
it's a continuation of chemical systems
and chemical networks and the what we we
call this one particular type of
chemistry and this behavior of chemistry
life
um but it is just one manifestation of
all the trillions of possible
permutations in which chemical reactions
can occur and we we assert specialness
to it because that's what we are and so
this is also true of intelligence you
could extend the same thing and say you
know we're we're looking for intelligent
life in the universe and then you sort
of where does where do you define
intelligence where where's that
Continuum of something that's really
like hers are we alone there may be a
Continuum of chemical systems a
Continuum of intelligences out there
and
um we have to be careful of our own
arrogance of assuming specialness about
what we are that we are some distinct
category of phenomena whereas the
universe doesn't really care about what
category we are it's just doing what
it's doing and doing everything in you
know infinite infinite diversity and
infinite combinations essentially what
it's doing and so we are we are taking
this one slice and saying No this has to
be treated separately and um I I'm open
to the idea that it could be a truly
separate phenomena but it may just be
like uh like a snowflake every
snowflake's different it may just be
that this one particular
iteration is another variant of the vast
Continuum yeah maybe the algorithm of
natural selection itself is an invention
of Earth
I kind of also tend to suspect that this
this whatever the algorithm is it kind
of operates at all levels throughout the
Universe but maybe this is a very kind
of peculiar thing
that
um
where there's a bunch of chemical
systems that compete against each other
somehow for survival under limited
resources and that's a very Earth-like
thing we have a nice balance of there's
a large number of resources is enough to
have a bunch of different kinds of
systems competing but not so many that
uh they they get lazy yeah and maybe
that's why bacteria were very lazy for a
long time maybe they had they didn't
have much competition quite possibly I
mean I I try to as as fun as it is to
get into the speculation about
um the definitions of of life and what
life does and this gross network of
possibilities
honestly for me the strongest argument
for remaining agnostic is is to avoid
that that bias in assessing data and
we've seen we've seen it I mean first of
all I talked about my channel
um and maybe last year or two years ago
you know he's a very famous astronomer
who in the 19th century was claiming the
evidence of canals on Mars and from him
from his perspective and even at the
time culturally it was widely accepted
that Mars would of course have life I
mean I think it's seems silly to us but
it was kind of similar arguments to what
we're using now about EXO plan is that
well of course there must be life in the
universe how could it just be here and
so it seemed obvious to people that when
you looked at Mars with its polar caps
even you know its atmosphere had Seasons
it seemed obvious to them that that too
would be a place where life Not only was
present but had emerged to a
civilization which actually was fairly
comparable in technology to our own
because it was building Canal systems
um ecorsicana system seems a bizarre
tennis a signature to us but it was a
product of their time to them that was
The Cutting Edge in technology it should
be a warning shot actually a little bit
for us that if we think you know solar
panels or building star links or
whatever space mining is like an
inevitable Technic signature that may be
laughably Antiquated compared to what
other civilizations far more advanced
than this may be doing and so anyway
Percival LOL he was he I think was a
product of his time that he thought life
was there inevitably he even wrote about
it extensively and so when he saw these
lines these linear on the surface of
Mars to him it was just obvious they
were canals and he was he that was
experimenters bias playing out he was
told for one that he had basically the
greatest eyesight out of any of his
peers and ophthalmologists had told him
that in Boston that his eyesight was you
know absolutely spectacular so he just
was convinced everything he saw was was
real
um and secondly he was convinced there
was life there and so it to him it just
added up and then that kind of wasted
you know Decades of research of of
treating the idea of Mars being
inhabited by this canal civilization
um but on the other hand it's maybe not
a waste because it is a lesson in
history of how we should be always on
guard against our own preconceptions and
biases about what yeah whether life is
out there and furthermore what types of
things life might do if it is there
if I were running this simulation which
we'll also talk about because you make
the case against it but if I'm running a
simulation I would definitely put you in
a room with an alien and just to see you
mentally freak out for hours at a time
oh you for sure would have thought you
will be convinced that you've lost your
mind I mean no not not that but I mean
like if we discover Life we've
discovered interesting new physical
phenomena I think the right approach is
definitely to be extremely skeptical and
be very very careful about things you
want to be true that's that's yeah I
would say I'm not like some extreme
denialist of evidence if there was if
there was compelling evidence for life
on another planet I would be the first
one to be celebrating that and be
shaking hands with the alien on the
White House alone whatever that would be
you know I grew up with Star Trek and
that was my fantasy was to you know be
Captain Kirk and fly across the Stars
meaning of the civilization so there's
nothing more I'd want to be true as I've
said but um
we we just have to guard against it when
we're we're assessing data
um but uh I'm I have to say I'm very
skeptical that we will ever have that uh
Star Trek moment even if even if there
are other civilizations out there
they're never going to be at a point
which is in technological lock step with
us similar level development even uh
intellectually the idea that they could
uh have a conversation with us even
through a translator I mean we can't
communicate with humpback whales we
can't make it with dolphins in a
meaningful way we can sort of bark
orders at them but we can't uh have
abstract conversations with them about
things
um and so the idea that we will ever
have that fulfilling conversation I'm
deeply skeptical of and I think a lot of
us are drawn to that it is maybe a
replacement for God to some degree that
that Father Figure civilization that
might step in teach us the area of our
ways and bestow wisdom Upon Our
civilization but they could equally be a
giant fungus that has doesn't even
understand the idea of social
socialization because it's the only
entity on this planet it just swells
over the entire surface and it doesn't
it's incredibly intelligent because
maybe each node communicates with each
other to create essentially a giant
neural net but it has no sense of what
communication even is and so
alien life is out there is surely going
to be extremely diverse I'm pretty
skeptical that we'll ever get that that
fantasy moment I always had as a kid of
having a dialogue within the
civilization